- Do you think, cuz I feel
like you do get political in a good way.
Do you feel like you'd
ever get into politics?
Would you ever do that?
- If I can figure out
a way to run for office
and still maintain my integrity
which I'm not sure is
something that you can do.
- That's the saddest statement.
It's so true.
- I know, I know.
I think that our politicians get into it
for the right reasons,
and on both sides get very
caught up in the power of it.
- Also how to get out there.
Like to have support.
- It's such a bureaucracy.
And they're constantly fundraising
and they go where the money goes
and it's just very easy to get caught up
in all of that.
- That pattern.
- I'm an activist.
I'm happy to be an activist
and I feel like I get a lot done.
If at some point I could figure
out how to get as much done
and run for office.
I'm not saying no.
- Against the idea.
- And also my kids are little.
And you have to be in D.C. so much.
So maybe as they get older.